[musique]
Salut, juste pour info cette vidéo ce n'est pas un placement de produit.
On a pas reçu d'argent pour ça.
Par contre à la fin de la vidéo je vous fait gagner la console avec Simon, alias "Le jeux vidéal".
[Simon] Enchanté !
Bref à la fin de la vidéo on vous dit comment gagner la console
mais pour l'instant on va l'essayer.
Bienvenue sur la chaîne "Mental Gaming " !
[musique]
[S] Regardons la vidéo
[F] Regardons la vidéo
[S] Est ce qu'on doit faire pareil ?
[F] C'est Studio Vrac ! *rires*
[S] Ouah c'est eux !
[S] Thomas et Cyril.
Voilà Thomas a perdu. Mais est ce que ça serait pas habituel ?
[F] C'est pas faux ! *rire*
*Jouent au duel*
[S] Qui l'a eu?
[F] Je sais pas...
[F] Mon doigt il a rippé mais...
[S] Wouah on s'est tué...
[F] Match nul.
[S] Oh non!
[F] C'est énorme. Bravo !
[S] On était fait pour s'entendre.
[F] C'est énorme !
*Jouent au duel*
[S] Moi je reste. Toi tu fais des *Pioufff* [F] Ouais
[S] Matrix
[F] Non
[S] YESSS !!!
[F] Je méprise mon adversaire, j'ai pas besoin de le regarder.
[S] *prend voix cassé* Eh mec, tu as tué ma femme, mon chien.
[S] Ah il faut recharger
[F] Je te méprise jusqu'au bout je joue même plus en fait.
*Jouent au duel*
[S] Oh, il y a eu deux tirs !
[S] Il y en a un qui était après l'autre.
[F] Putain je suis une merde ! *rires*
[S] C'est une victoire !
[S] Je suis imbattable au Far-West!
[F] Est-ce que j'ai tiré sur toi, au moins?
[F] Au moins ça...
[S] Je crois que oui...
[S] Oh oui.
[S] Ah moi par contre je t'ai visé très bas.
[F] Moi j'ai la décence au moins, de tirer dans le cœur tu vois.
*accent chinois* [F] Bonjour Sensei. [S] Bonjour.
[F] C'est presque raciste, [S] c'est presque raciste ouais *rires*
[S] Je vais éviter de te la mettre dans la tête.
[S] Bien joué
[F] Le petit scarabée n'a pas de citation chinoise, mais voudrais en dire une quand même.
[S] Non !
[F] Par la poussière de diamant !
[F] Voilà c'est ça que je cherchais
[S] C'est quoi? C'est...
[F] C'est quoi? Si vous êtes abonné à la chaîne de Simon, pensez à vous désabonner,
[F] ce mec n'a pas les références des Chevaliers du Zodiac, ce n'est pas possible !
[S] Ah bah c'est bien ce qui me semblait, c'est les Chevaliers du Zodiac [F] Bien sûr!
[F] Je pensais vraiment qu'il y aurait des trucs d'anticipation qui nous permettrait de parler de non-verbal en même temps,
[F] mais c'est pas le cas du tout puisqu'à chaque fois on doit réagir à un signal commun.
[F] Donc on fait quand même la vidéo puisque ce serait dommage d'avoir cette console à vous faire gagner et de pas le faire.
[F] Cette console t'aime !
[S] Oui je crois.
[F] Comme tu l'avais eu en avance je pense que t'as...
[F] Trop rapide !
[F] On te l'a toujours dit, ton ex m'en avait parlé de ça.
[S] Quoi ? Tu la connais ?
[F] C'est ma mère je te rappelle.
[S] Fallait pas l'dire !
[F] Trop rapide ! [S] Encore ? [F] Bien sûr !
[S] Non mais toi t'es plus fort mentalement parlant, moi je vais perdre.
[F] Trop lent...
[S] Et je la rentre ? [F] Et tu la rentres.
[S] Ok, et cette fois je la fais en entier.
[F] Je veux plus jamais t'entendre dire cette phrase.
[S] Quelle phrase? [F] "Je la rentres".
[F] Tu rentres rien du tout.
[F] Trop rapide !
[F] Détournement d'attention, confusion mentale, recherche d'image, c'est bon.
[F] Hé, pourtant t'étais pas loin. T'as vu comme c'est humiliant quand le gagnant te dis ça?
[F] Alors, Neville Londubat, comment vas-tu?
[S] Neville ?!
[S] T'sais qu'il est devenu beau gosse aujourd'hui méfie toi
[F] C'est vrai, mais moi je parle du 1.
[F] Wingardium Leviosa !
[S] Expelliarmus !
[S] Allez ! Allez ! [F] Voldemort ! Avada Kedavra !
[S] Allez ! Ça passe !
[F] T'as vu ce qu'il m'a mis ? Il m'a mis que j'étais trop agressif !
[F] Comme d'habitude, on fait gagner le joueur de gauche !
[S] Bien sûr, et j'ai la même réaction après si tu veux.
[F] Alors notre but est de défaire... d'accord ok.
[F] Ouais, mais faut pas le ré-enchaîner...
[S] Hé tu traces!
*paroles en accéléré*
[S] Non non non non non non non NON !
[F] Putain, c'était pas grand chose hein.
[S] Ah c'était chaud !
[F] T'es droitier toi à la base ?
[S] Ah on a des vies et tout quoi [F] Ouais.
[F] Bah ! Enfin !
[S] Faut se battre...Faut se battre !
[F] C'est chaud hein, quand même.
[F] En fait je t'attaque à chaque fois que tu bloques.
[S] Non, non...[F] Ça y est, j'ai trouvé comment faire !
[F] Ainsi s'achève, l'humiliation, de Simon!
[F] Au départ j'espérais vraiment que je pourrai vous donner des indices sur le non-verbal en jouant à deux,
[F] et puis en fait comme le jeu ne marche qu'avec des signaux, c'était complètement pas possible.
[F] Mais du coup, bah on n'allait pas ne pas faire la vidéo et on a quand même essayé la Switch, qui est bien rigolote !
[F] Après, moi j'y connais pas grand chose en jeux vidéo.
[F] Lui, il s'y connait mieux que moi en vidéo, Simon. Si vous connaissez pas le Jeu Vidéal, t'avais fait une vidéo avec moi sur ma chaîne
[F] J'avais fait un "A quoi tu joues?" ( [S] Exact ) avec toi
[F] Je vous invite à découvrir sa chaîne, qui est dans la description et qui doit être aussi quelque part là-haut.
[S] Fabien est venu parler de "Civilization" sur la chaîne [F] Oui, j'adore ce jeu !
[F] Alors malheureusement j'ai découvert que après qu'il y avait deux jeux de bluff dans la console, celui avec les  billes et celui avec les dés.
On n'a pas pu les essayer parce que maintenant Simon est reparti à Stockholm.
Mais si ça vous tente, je referai un vidéo dessus, je mets un sondage juste là. Et je pourrais bien me refaire prêter une Switch pour ça
Pourquoi "prêter", parce que celle ci, on va vous l'offrir, on vous l'a dit. Déjà, merci beaucoup à CDiscount, c'est eux qui nous l'on envoyé
et nous on a décidé de vous la renvoyer, à vous les abonnés.
Pour ça c'est très simple, je mets un message sur Twitter aujourd'hui. Et pour participer au tirage au sort il suffit de le RT. Je fais le tirage au sort dans 7 jours tout pile.
Donc samedi d'après. Et si vous voulez être cool, vous pouvez en même temps follow CDiscount, et Simon et moi.
N'oubliez pas que demain à 17H30 je fais le live, ici, sur la chaîne ! Je sais que c'est les élections mais justement ça nous fera passer le temps, en attendant les résulats.
Et pour le concours du trophée, exceptionnellement, il n'y a pas d'indices dans cette vidéo. Ne cherchez pas, ne cherchez pas, ne cherchez pas je vous dis ! Je suis sûr qu'il y en a qui vont chercher... Ne cherchez pas.
Ciao !
[musique]